hi guys I'm back in this video we're
gonna talk about the 13 insulin triggers
okay now as you may or may not know
insulin is behind so many health
problems and if you could just
understand all the triggers and avoid
these things you can be very very
healthy so what I did is I out of this
book I summarized all of the triggers to
increasing insulin and just realize that
we need normal insulin but we don't need
excessive amounts of insulin so when you
have high levels of insulin it causes
the receptor that it's supposed to be
received in to downgrade and become
resistive and blocked so that's called
insulin resistance and then it sends a
signal back to the pancreas increasing
your insulin so you have a situation we
have too much insulin yet it's
ineffective it's not working okay okay
so let's start with number one sugar and
I'm talking about all the sugars okay
like dextrose high fructose corn syrup
table sugar brown sugar raw sugar honey
all the sugars number two refined grains
in the form of breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits things like that
number three frequency of eating every
time you eat you trigger insulin so the
more times you eat the worse it is
that's why we do in a minute fasting
number four there's an insulin scale
that measures all the non carbohydrate
things that can trigger insulin and lean
proteins will trigger insulin more than
fattier proteins so you don't want to
focus on lean low fat protein you want
to get the whole fat in there as Nature
has provided number five excessive
protein too much protein can trigger
insulin so the optimum amount is between
three and six ounces if you're a real
big guy or you're doing in a minute
fasting you're having less frequent
meals then consume a little bit more but
try not to go too much number six soy
oil which most definitely is genetically
modified and even corn soil and other
oils as well but it's sprayed with
glyphosate okay this is an herbicide
Roundup Ready part of the GMO thing so
we want to avoid soy oil because that
can trigger insulin resistance and then
spike insulin trans fats
that's all the hydrogenated oils you
want to avoid all that that can actually
cause insulin resistance and increase
insulin cortisol that's the adrenal
stress hormone and that includes all the
medication that has cortisol in a
synthetic version like prednisone shots
cortisol creams things like that
steroids number-9 diuretics so many
people are on high blood pressure
medication and this is they use a
diuretic which gets rid of fluid but one
of the side effects it causes insulin
resistance which then increases your
insulin causing more blood pressure okay
number 10 statins it's a cholesterol
medication causes insulin resistance
increasing insulin thereby increasing
cholesterol it's crazy
number 11 MSG monosodium glutamate
another name for that would be modified
food starch it's in so many foods it's
in fast-food restaurants it's in a lot
of other restaurants so if the food
tastes a bit too good suspect MSG and
avoid it because it can increase insulin
this is probably why you go to a Chinese
restaurant and you eat and an hour later
you're starving why because the blood
Sugar's go down and now you're hungry
again okay you're not satisfied number
12 and 13-hour mineral deficiencies and
vitamin deficiencies can set you up for
insulin resistance and thereby increase
insulin so low potassium potassium
deficiencies magnesium deficiencies low
sodium or low salt diet can increase the
risk of getting insulin resistance so
this is one of the things that doctors
recommend go in a low salt diet thereby
creating higher insulin which then
causes the retention of sodium it's
crazy
okay zinc deficiency you need zinc to
make insulin zinc is necessary to
support the cells that make insulin the
beta cells in fact the number one cell
in the body that absorbs the most zinc
is the cells that make insulin the beta
cells so if you're low in zinc it can
set you up for diabete
okay low chromium can do it high levels
of calcium can cause incident resistance
low b1 thiamine low vitamin D and low
vitamin A all right so here you have it
these are the things that can set you up
for insulin resistance and increase
insulin hey guys a lot of you already
have my book some of you don't but this
new edition called the new body type
guide is an upgrade from my last edition
called the seven principles of fat
burning it has 156 images 378 pages full
glossary I talked about keto in a minute
fasting the body types in detail I have
a new stressed chapter I'm going to show
you exactly what to eat any
comprehensive FAQ I put a link down
below check it out